واقفل الفيديو ينورنا الفنان محمود الغياث
محمود يسعد صباحك نورنا فصباح العربيه
شكرا على تواجدك معنا
المتميز وانت متميزه دائما شكرا على هذا
التقديم صباح الخير عليكم وان شاء الله
تكونوا دائما سعيده
بانك اصغر فنان يلحن ويغني ولو هذه
الجماهير الكبير على مواقع التواصل بين
الجمهور في الحفلات المباشره حدثنا اكثر
مدينه الاستديو صغير
بغداد انا واصدقائي وبعدين اتطور الموضوع
الكبار اشتغل شركات همم ناجحه يعني داخل
العراق
شركات ضمن اجتهادي اكيد والحمد لله والشكر
انه توفقنا وصلنا لهذه المنطقه اللي هي
لابد انه لازم يكون بعد وراءها تكمله تكون
قد حسن ظن الجميع
يبقى انت بلشت مسيرتك المهنيه في 2017
وكان لك اغاني ناجحه لكن اشتهرت بسرعه
البرق بعد ما غنيت ربي ارزقني شو السر
هالاغنيه الحمد لله الاغنيه لاقت نجاح كلش
حلو بالنسبه الي انا كنان بعد من ثلاث
سنوات بالسنه الثالثه صار عندي هذا النجاح
طبعا هو بالبدايه توفيق من رب العالمين
واكيد بعد التخطيط وتحضير ضمن الكل يعني
كنا نشتغل به بس همم انا حسيت هذه الاغنيه
اكثر اغنيه من بيننا البوم اللي طرحتها
بسنه 2019 اللي هو كان البوم مليون واحد
اكثر اغنيه دخلت للعوائل والقلوب والناس
كانت سهله بالنسبه للاستماع يعني من كل
فئات العمريه
اه
ربي رزقني فد عشق بس هو اللي ببالي صار
النفس مالي ما غير يحلالي
خلاني اطير بلا جناح يمه ايش حلو عطره
دللني كل عمره كلي تحت امرك الكويت
همم اتوجهت الاغنيه الاصاله وحدها وصارت
الاغنيه اول ما نزلت همم ترند ما شاء الله
وحققت نجاح كلش كبير وانا بالنسبه الي كنت
يعني
متحضر لهذا التعاون من زمان
واماكن تعاونات باقيه والفنانه والنجمه
العراقيه اكيده واجلها تحيتي همم رحمه
رياض ان شاء الله راح يطرح العمل بالايام
الجايه راح يكون مختلف نوعا ما عليها هي
كاديو وكي تصوير عنهم شويه اغششوني من
الكليب همم شفت همم كم لقطه شفت انه راح
يكون يعني
يا محمود
شو السر الاغنيه العراقيه ليش اكتسحت
الساحه
السرب الاغنيه العراقيه انه هي تكون اغنيه
شامله اييه
خصوصا الكلام العراقي كلام يوصل للقلب
بسرعه كلام اييه كل المنطقه العربيه
تفتهمه احنا بالاجمع عنه احنا دائما نتفق
على انه اللغه المصريه هي اشهر لغه
بالوطن العربي او اشهر لهجه
عربيه بس هي لهجه يعني اشهر لهجه
بالوطن العربي لكن الاغنيه العراقيه همم
صارت متربع على عرش الاغاني العربيه
بالفتره الاخيره لانه الكلام والشعر
العراقي همم باوزان مفتوحه
وبمعاني حلوه ودعم الاغنيه العراقيه
انطباع انه هي حزينه دائما بس همم الحمد
لله كل ملحنينه وكل شعراءنا شطار يجددون
ما بين فتره حتى يطرحون الاعمال دائما
تشوفوها الغزاليه اللي هي اخر فتره تحياتي
لهم وان شاء الله الله يوفقهم ويوفقنا
كعرب حتى نوصل الاغنيه العربيه للعالميه
ان شاء الله واحنا منك اغنيه عراقيه من
القلب
اه
[موسيقى]
تخوف فكره
غيابك
ما احب من تجي بالي
اشوف الموت يا الغالي وقلبي يلعب بحالي
ويؤذيني
يعني الموت اقول لك ولا تفارقني له لحظه
يلب غيرك صعب ارض بدونك
تسكتين نبضه ولك عيني
اصير ترى ياخذني الهوى
ينسيني
يا الحب
مكفيني ولك عيني
اضافه الى اغاني الضاربه يا محمود وحفلات
الكناجح في الوطن العربي يسمعنا في اشاره
مسلسل شفناك عضو في لجنه التحكيم ملكه او
حفل ملكه جمال حدثنا اكثر عن مشاريعك
مستقبليه
الحمد لله انه نحن من بعد هاي المرحله
اللي تخطيناها
بنحضر الى اعمال ان شاء الله تكون همم
مفاجاه بالنسبه الي انا ك جمهور محمود
الغاياته ومتابعين اللي يحبوني دائما
ينتظرون من عندي الاحسن
دائما يحفزوني على الشغله الجديده والقوه
والمسجات توصلني بس اني اقول التحضير راح
يكون مفاجاه جدا جدا بالنسبه حتى للجمهور
العراقي ومتابعين الاغنيه العراقيه همم
وان شاء الله تحضير اكو فيديوهات بانه
وبين الفنانين عرب ان شاء الله الله
يوفقنا بها اخر اغنيه
من يقول
ضحكاتي صديق لها
منو يقول
سهله لدمع نازلها
بطلت السهر كافي منو يقول
كفيلك الله غافي لك موزه
حنيت لك وتوجعت شاب بدونك شبيت من زين قلت
لك كذبت لك مو زين
شكرا جزيلا